ANAGHA DIWANJI: In
this video, we'll
show you how to detect anomalies
using Streaming Analytics
and AI.
My name is Anagha Diwanji.
And my colleague
Prerna Bellara and I
are solution engineers
for Google Cloud.
Many companies are dealing
with the proliferation
of data and difficulty in
making sense of that data
at the speed required
to make it useful.
This solution aims at sifting
through the mass of data
to the events that need
additional attention--
those outliers that indicate
that something is not
going as expected.
Now, what is anomaly detection?
Spotting the unusual,
catching fraud,
and discovering
strange activity.
All of this sounds like Sherlock
Holmes solving a mystery.
That's what anomaly detection
is, except we may not
have a clear suspect
to search for,
and you may not even
know what the crime is.
When you see this example,
do you spot any anomalies?
First thought, it's fairly easy
to see the large spike appears
to be an outlier.
But what if you have a
large sample of data?
Now the perception changes, and
what appeared to be an anomaly
turns out to be part of a
regular and familiar pattern.
In this, the anomalous
behavior is not the fact
that there are spikes
but the observation
that their frequency
fluctuates during an episode.
The highlighted region
denotes an anomaly
because the same
low value exists
for an abnormally long time.
Anomalies are not defined
by their own characteristics
but in contrast
to what is normal.
The speed with which businesses
are able to identify anomalies
impacts their
options for response.
For example, not detecting
a fraudulent financial
transaction immediately
and instead within hours
or even days often results in
writing off the financial loss.
On the other hand, finding
the anomalous transaction
in seconds allows
for the invalidation
of the transaction
and corrective actions
to prevent future fraud.
Similarly, by
detecting anomalies
in industrial
equipment, manufacturers
can predict and prevent
catastrophic failures
that could cause capital
and human loss by initiating
proactive equipment shutdown
and preventative maintenance.
Likewise for retail,
we can see this
being used to help
manage inventory, detect
fraud, and track user
behavior patterns.
Another example of an
industry application
is a telco company doing
subscriber analytics
and specifically focusing on
detecting anonymous wireless
traffic, real-time fraud
detection on call and SIM,
and user behavior patterns.
And across all these
industries, cybersecurity
is top of mind for
most customers because
of economic costs of intrusion
and security attacks.
Let's talk about how to design a
system for intrusion detection.
Let's deep dive into
our story for today.
In our story, we have
Stacy, who's a data analyst.
Her main role is to
manage and monitor
the network for a
large corporation.
She needs to ensure everything
is running smoothly.
And if there's an outage
or unusual behavior,
she needs to report it and
take corrective action.
Stacy's company
currently has a hard time
anticipating network
traffic changes,
which creates impediments
in identifying
cybersecurity attacks.
They want to catch unusual
behavior and security attacks
in real time and take action.
Leveraging Google Cloud
Streaming service,
Stacy can monitor the
network, analyze the traffic,
and now has opportunity
to review and take
action such as file a
ticket in near real time.
When anomalies are found,
the solution automatically
sends an alert to Stacy
and updates network health
dashboards.
Now, let's see an
overview of how
Stacy implemented anomaly
detection in Google Cloud
environment.
There's four major
components to this--
ingest, extract and
train, predict, and alert.
The first step is ingesting
unlabeled streaming data
from all the sources.
Google Cloud Pub/Sub
and Google Cloud Storage
make it easy to
ingest streaming data.
Next, we transform and store
this data in Google BigQuery,
extract features using
Dataflow, and train the model
with just some SQL.
After training this
data, we use Dataflow
to allow for online real-time
reporting and highlighting
outliers.
But it isn't just enough to
detect anomalies and monitor
this data.
The key is the action we take.
BI tools, such as
Tableau and Looker,
allow you to not only
view this information
but take appropriate action such
as informing the security team.
This was just a brief overview.
Now let's take a closer look at
each of these four components.
My colleague Prerna Bellara
will take it forward.
PRERNA BELLARA: Let's assume
I'm Stacy, an analyst tasked
with solving this business
problem that we discussed
earlier.
First, I'll look into
the GitHub repository
to understand all of the
four steps mentioned earlier.
The first step,
you might recall,
would be to ingest the data.
Google Cloud's Pub/Sub
topic can help us
with the streaming ingestion.
In order to do so, we also need
to simulate production data
to train our model.
The photo on the
right shows the schema
for the model, which
resembles a NetFlow schema.
We notice about 250,000 events
per second in my production
environment, which
comes up to about 20
terabytes of data from
heterogeneous sources
coming through a Pub/Sub topic,
some of which will be labeled,
some maybe unlabeled.
Let's look at the next step.
Now that we've set
up the ingestion,
the next question
is, how do we ensure
the solution is scalable?
If you recall, we were
generating or anticipating
250,000 events per second.
We need to aggregate this data.
This ties to the second step,
which is extract and train.
Using Dataflow [? BIM ?] and
its [INAUDIBLE] transform
such as minimum,
maximum, and count,
we can ingest and aggregate
these logs or events,
thereby reducing the
number of elements
or the amount or volume of
elements from 11 gigabytes
to 1.03 gigabytes,
as you can see.
Additionally, Dataflow [? BIM ?]
allows us to autoscale, thereby
generating or helping
us build a pipeline that
is production ready.
We will use [? BQMS ?]
k-means clustering model
to train this extracted data.
We've decided to
use k-means as a--
since it's a common algorithm
used for unsupervised machine
learning.
As you can see, I wrote the
SQL query to create the model,
ran the command, and in 15
minutes we have a model.
Configuration is easy.
Simply mention the columns
I wanted as features
and set the number of clusters.
This is great, because machine
learning requires some trial
and error, and the
quick turnaround time
helps me to play with
the configuration
and determine the most optimal
combination for my use case.
Another great feature for an
analyst is the scheduled query.
I don't want to just create a
model one time and leave it.
I want it to learn continuously
and be updated with the latest
patterns.
Using a scheduled query and
a [? stored ?] procedure,
I can rerun this query
in a timely manner,
thereby keeping
my model updated.
Additionally, once
the module is created
we will calculate the normalized
distance from each centroid
or grouping to determine if
the input that we received
is too far from the
cluster, thereby deeming it
as an outlier.
Now that the model is ready,
it's time to detect outliers.
How do we do this?
The answer is Dataflow.
We pass the normalized data
in the pipeline as an input
and reuse this data to
calculate how far our input
data is from the center.
If it meets a
distance threshold,
we don't throw them
as an outlier--
we store them as an outlier
in the BigQuery table.
The result, we are now
notified of the outlier
and can provide
little to no downtime.
Now that we have enabled
real-time detection,
it's time to view our
results, and most importantly,
take appropriate action.
We will leverage Google's
Looker Dashboard to do this.
Let's take a look.
As you can see, in
this Looker Dashboard,
I can see the number
of events, the source,
whether it was an anomaly,
as well as the bytes.
There is another column
over here called Actions,
which allows me to take
appropriate action.
I can either create a Jira
ticket, text a security
consultant, or email the
security team, thereby
notifying my team
of the right action.
You can also use any
other third-party tool
that is supported by Google
Cloud for your reporting needs.
In summary, we've built this
in a short time, processed
over 250,000 events
using Dataflow.
We can consume all of this
20 terabytes of daily data
from data sources.
We trained and evaluated
1 terabyte data
in 15 minutes using SQL.
We found outliers
in near real time
and took appropriate action.
We've covered a lot of ground.
For more information
on how to implement
this in your environment, please
check out the GitHub link.